einmal im monat treffen sie sich zu
ihrer mahnwache für israel und gegen
antisemitismus in der hamburger
innenstadt für michael er endet sie im
september in der notaufnahme schwer
verletzt durch einen faustschlag es
begann mit beleidigungen erinnert er
sich zwei wochen nach dem angriff drei
jugendliche hatten sich von den israel
flaggen provoziert gefühlt
ihr [ __ ]
dann free palästina scheiß juden
und dann war es so meine mutter stand ja
neben mir und dann riefen sie noch ich
finde deine mutter oder bekam ich von
dem anderen von dem lockenkopf sofort
eine hier aufs gesicht geknallt dass die
brille zerbrach hatte mir hier auf den
kiefer gehauen und fielen um
michael r muss operiert werden der
60-jährige jude droht auf einem auge zu
erblinden
ich habe jetzt hier so eine metallplatte
drin die wahrscheinlich dass unten
ausfüllt damit dieser knochen wieder
irgendwie zusammen wächst ja ich denke
mal so ist das dann mit ihnen das auge
nicht abrutschen wird der mutmaßliche
täter aram a 16 jahre alt die
ermittlungen laufen jeder redet über
antisemitismus von rechts wir hier sind
in den sechs jahren noch nie von nazis
oder rechten angegriffen würden wir
werden immer von muslimen bedrängt
bespuckt ihr scheiß juden warum steht
ihr hier das höre eigentlich ständig ist
schon normal die zahl der
antisemitischen straftaten in
deutschland hat einen höchststand
erreicht
die meisten täter werden dem rechten
spektrum zugeordnet doch es gibt auch
sehr viele anfeindungen durch muslime
ich glaube dass der islamische
antisemitismus stark unterschätzt wird
und das ist aber eben nicht nur hass auf
israel sondern das steckt die
vorstellung dahinter das zionisten auf
der ganzen welt sich verschworen haben
gegen muslime und das ist gefährlich
weil es da um einen identitätskampf geht
[Musik]
mitten auf dem heumarkt in köln schreien
sie ihren judenhass unverhohlen heraus
anlass der wiederaufgeflammte nahost
konflikt im mai
diese kölner haben die kundgebung damals
dokumentiert ihre film- aufnahmen
belegen die demonstranten feiern den
anführer einer radikalislamischen
terrororganisation
[Applaus]
deutlicher kann man es nicht machen das
massiv antisemitisches soll der jüdische
staat vernichtet werden sollen juden
vertrieben oder getötet werden und
israel soll geschichte werden in deren
augen das wird in deutschland was er von
sich behauptet dass solidarität mit
israel staatsraison seien sei wird
geduldet drum herum steht polizei und
bewacht die demo und greift bei
derartigen dingen nicht ein
auch vor der synagoge in gelsenkirchen
hetzen muslime gegen juden neben
palästinensischen auch türkischen
flaggen zur gleichen zeit mitte mai
heißt der türkische präsident erdogan
die stimmung via facebook an er hetzt
gegen juden
das töten wird in ihrer natur sie werden
erst durch das blutsauger satt kann
erklärt
erdogans sprachrohr in deutschland der
türkische islam verband ditib zur
eröffnung der zentralmoschee in köln vor
drei jahren reiste er persönlich an
deutsche die tib imame werden von
erdogans religionsbehörde ausgebildet
und dürfen in nordrhein westfalen seit
diesem jahr den religionsunterricht
wieder mitbestimmen wer
in berlin ist mitglied der deutschen
islamkonferenz
er kritisiert die tib grenze sich von
antisemitischen äußerungen aus ankara
nicht eindeutig ab die übergroße
mehrzahl der imame wird auch in den
nächsten jahren aus der türkei
importiert und die werden natürlich auch
probleme mit nach deutschland rein
bringen deswegen ist es wenig
nachvollziehbar warum man jetzt die
ditib wieder in diese neue kommission
für den islamischen religionsunterricht
in der nrw aufgenommen hat was sagt die
tib zu den antisemitismus vorwürfen der
verband in köln antwortet nicht auf
fragen von frontal
hamburg tag der offenen tür in der
blauen moschee
das islamische zentrum hamburg kurz ict
wird immer wieder mit antisemitismus
vorwürfen konfrontiert und seit
jahrzehnten vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet
muhammad mofa thiel leiter des etat- und
gleichzeitig vertreter des obersten
führers im iran ist bereit zu den
vorwürfen stellung zu nehmen die eigenen
kameras laufen nicht
der hamburger verfassungsschutz
stuft das islamische zentrum als
islamistisch ein und sagt es verbreitet
homophobie antisemitisches gedankengut
was sagen sie dazu
wir haben einen sehr freundschaftlichen
kontakt mit den juden und auf keinen
fall akzeptieren wir diesen vorwurf es
gibt keine belege und zeichen für solche
beschuldigungen die auf das islamische
zentrum zu treffen
dabei hat der verfassungsschutz erst im
juli einen sonderbericht veröffentlicht
warnt vor dem iz als außenposten des
teheraner regimes das zentrum verbreite
schriften die zahlreiche antisemitische
stereotypen enthalten
zionisten und deren hintermänner werden
als eine verschlagene listige und emsige
bruderschaft bezeichnet
das islamische zentrum klagt nun gegen
den verfassungsschutz für sie steht viel
auf dem spiel
2012 unterzeichnete olaf scholz als
bürgermeister der stadt homburg einen
staatsvertrag mit den muslimischen
verbänden auch das etat ist seit dem
partner der vertrag soll verlängert
werden das ist natürlich gefährlich wenn
man bedenkt dass wir es hier eben mit
einem islamistischen akteur zu tun haben
und müssen da genauer hingucken weil
eben die gefahr besteht dass sonst
dieser hass und der antisemitismus und
die verschwörungs ideologien immer
weiter verbreitet werden
judenhass verbreitet sich zunehmend auch
über die sozialen medien wie gefährlich
das werden kann erfuhr die jüdische
gemeinde in hagen an yom kippur dem
höchsten feiertag ein 16 jähriger
syrischer flüchtlinge soll einen
bombenanschlag geplant haben er sitzt in
untersuchungshaft
sein vater und bruder sind inzwischen
wieder auf freien fuß auf facebook
finden wir das profil des schülers
erfolgt den botschaften von mohammed al
arifi ein salafistischer prediger aus
saudi arabien mit 1,3 millionen verloren
der postet radikalislamische und
antisemitische inhalte
er bezeichnet juden als enkel von affen
und schweinen
wir wollen mit der familie sprechen
wollen wissen warum sich ihr sohn
radikalisiert hat
[Musik]
wir sind im deutschen fernsehen wir
wollten
die jüdische gemeinde in hagen steht
noch immer unter schock die kratzspuren
der sprengstoff spürhunde sind noch auf
dem boden der synagoge zu sehen der
mutmaßliche täter wollte laut ermittlern
möglichst viele menschen treffen sie ist
für mich nicht überraschend
das ist nur die frage wann sowas
passiert ja und ich versuche immer da zu
machen ist hier eine akute problem der
zentralrat der juden beobachtet den
muslimischen antisemitismus mit
wachsender sorge wir bekommen mehr davon
berichtet dass
menschen die ideen die man glaube ich
als als
islam
fundamentalisten einordnen kann dass die
zunehmend sich an aktivitäten beteiligen
die der jüdischen gemeinschaft ja wie
soll es in den versuchen schaden
zuzufügen
also ich fürchte dass es noch
gefährlicher werden wird in hamburg
wollen sie sich nicht einschüchtern
lassen sie demonstrieren weiter unter
polizeischutz
[Musik]